eli lilly has announced a pause in
clinical trials for a coronavirus drug
this comes after johnson and johnson
paused its global vaccine trial
both companies say safety is taking
priority over
speed adriana diaz has our report
drug maker eli lilly announced a
temporary hold on its coronavirus
antibody therapy tuesday
it's a drug similar to the one taken by
president trump since his return to the
white house the president has heavily
promoted antibody therapies to the
public
it's totally safe but it's powerful
against this disease
so we're going to get it out to you the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases said tuesday that
the eli lilly trial was halted
following a recommendation from the
independent data and safety monitoring
board
and that the trial will be on hold until
october 26th
at the earliest cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus says these
types of causes are routine
this is nothing to cause great concern i
think it should be the opposite is the
public should look and say oh this is
amazing that they're really taking every
safety issue to heart
and looking deeply before restarting the
trial which in almost all cases they
have done
the pauses come as the need for
coronavirus treatment grows
with a rise in new cases in 37 states
a key driver gatherings at places like
family events
a recent cdc report found that a 13 year
old girl infected 11 people staying in
the same house
during a family vacation without masks
or social distancing
leading to cases in four states dr debra
burks of the white house coronavirus
task force is telling americans to be
prepared to adapt upcoming gatherings
like thanksgiving
to the realities of the pandemic this
virus
can spread among families and friends
if you are take your mask off and you're
primarily indoors
eli lilly said in a statement that this
pause is really out of an abundance of
caution also keep in mind
that it's not known if any sick patients
in either trial took the placebo
or actual treatment as for jonathan
johnson they say they are still
on track to complete enrollment for
their 60 000 person trial in the next
three months
some of that will happen here at
chicago's rush university medical center
tony science in action adriana thank you
very much